hi guys I'm Sam glam is deputy beauty
editor I'm cash out on a beach blogger
and makeup artist you are watching
glamour tries the new series where we
test out the latest and greatest in the
world of beauty today we're going to be
trying the new NARS
climax mascara I am on the hunt for a
mascara that will hold my lashes all day
long my lashes are super short and super
pale always wear false lashes I'm
obsessed with them I'm obsessed with the
volume we give today it's gonna be a
real test see what I think this mascara
I mean that's quite instant that is
quite impressive it's just really
buildable it doesn't clump the brush
actually distribute the product all
across my lashes it's coated them fully
from root to tip that's the mascara on
no mascara whatsoever great separation
great volume really feathery and that's
I'm look I'm going to be shooting so
let's see if it gives me the volume I
need on camera and if the volume and
lift lasts all day let's check back in a
bit
I've just finished filming the glam drop
and I thought I'd check it in because I
really liked how my lashes looked on
camera they're really looking nice and
long it's really good I'm just taking a
coffee break and I wanted to see what my
lashes look like it's so looking quite
bold and then look great on camera so
I've just taken a quick time out from
dinner to check on my mascara but it
still looks really lifted and full of
volume so I'm super happy
I am definitely taking this guy home
with me he has done a stellar job of
keeping my lashes curly all day long I
was a bit nervous to see how his mascara
at how about yeah as I opening as it was
when I first put it on and I'm just
in rust you can see it's still really
really lifted I think I'd go as far as
to say I put in my top three all-time
favorite mascara so it's pretty good
thank you so much for watching if you
try this mascara for yourself please let
us know in the comment sections below as
we'd love to know what you thought of it
don't forget to subscribe to glamour
UK's YouTube channel and follow glamour
UK
[Music]